[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Christopher Mad Dog Russo
a host of Mad Dog Unleashed awkward
situations here let me ask you the poll
question there out of all of those show
hey with the angels the Maverick
situation uh the Ravens with Lamar and
what's going on with the Packers and the
Jets and Aaron Rodgers oh good morning
Dan I bet it's a pleasure to be on I
love the golf stuff you did there and
you're right those Live players I would
take a run at kepka he won last week
he's healthier plus 400 was it four
thousand right what'd you say it was
four thousand I mean my God that's a
steal I'm with you a thousand percent on
that uh uh I think the Ravens is with
Lamar first of all time is going to last
six months it's too early to go big deal
on that yet uh the Packers eventually
will make this trade as it is and you
know the Kyrie thing is a little awkward
I totally agree uh but I think Lamar
right now the draft fourth coming you
know he he doesn't like them you know I
don't think it's a question of them not
liking him but I don't think he's worth
they don't want to pay him 200 million
dollars then they got a the compensation
with the two picks and everything else I
think that's the most awkward one that's
a very good job by your guys with that
the danettes with the four of them I
love those four but I would say Lamar uh
with the Ravens I think that's the most
awkward thing at the moment you think
the angels with Otani that gets worked
out long term not sure uh the one thing
I would say there Dan is I don't think
Mourinho wants to be the owner who
trades Otani in July so even if ohtani
and the team is awful and you know they
may not be who knows you know they off
to a decent start that even if they're
you know 20 ounce on July 15th July I
don't think he wants a trade Otani do
you want to be the owner who lets rotany
walk if Otani stays and he gives him a
what you would consider a decent offer
to sign a long-term deal and then he
leaves you don't get pounded if you let
him go at the deadline that's telling
everybody you won't have no plans of
signing him anyway and you look bad so I
don't think Mourinho is 80 years old
wants that on his resume so I think
Otani will be an angel no matter how bad
they are all year long yeah I just
wonder if you could get the biggest Hall
in baseball history for Otani and
granted I wouldn't want to be the GM who
traded him away but I'd also like to be
the GM who brought a winner to the
angels and I don't think that you're
going to win with Otani and trout I mean
you got the two favorites two of the top
three favorites for MVP in the American
League and you might not even make the
playoffs that's Cohen Mendon too the
problem with you're right the problem
with getting a long haul back there's
only a couple teams you could trade them
to that feel they could sign them long
term Dodgers and Yankees or maybe the
Mets those three I forget the Yankees
Mets and Dodgers would be those two so
you know if the Indians or the Guardians
wanted them what are you going to get
back because they know they can't sign
them it's a two-month rental yeah if
they trade into the Dodgers and if
you're a Mourinho you want to trade oh
Tony to the LA Dodgers I mean he's 30
miles away and you know maybe you chain
them to the Mets and maybe you can you
know fleece their farm system I guess
that's possible but I still think at the
end of the a day ohtani will play for
the angels all year long no matter what
the record is in July that's what I
would say right now I gave a stat
earlier that all 12 games on Thursday
were played in under three hours
which is nice but is is are these rules
having an impact here oh I think they
are Dan uh I mean listen opening day was
3 17 last year this year was 240
something 245 so I want the idea that
there's a lot more stolen bases a single
is a single uh I I think the rules uh
you know listen I think it's been so
much better look at the Sunday night
game how many Sunday night games last
forever and at 10 10 I'm sorry at 9 10
the game was at seven had nine ten there
in the top of the ninth inning with the
Rangers and the Phillies so I think it's
so much better uh I think it's long
overdue
um I think it's the quick it's just you
can sit there and watch it without you
know sitting there for four hours to
watch a ball game you know over game
eight of 162. so I think it's a big plus
I do think you've seen it this week
Machado Tim Anderson especially this
Machado the umpires are going to enforce
it so I don't think you're going to see
a situation where the umpires would get
lenient and you know not enforce that
pitch clock so I think overall it's been
a big plus I think it's hope baseball
and I've said this a lot and I don't
know how you feel about Danny and I
wasn't a big WBC guy but I do think
baseball's got a lot more momentum to
start the year than they've had in a
long time they had four and a half
million people watched that last game on
FS1 Japan and the United States they had
Otani and trout I didn't get that
wrapped up in it but a lot of people did
and then you throw in all the rules so I
think baseball did have a had a very
good start to their season you know when
you know you got the Masters you got the
final four so I think baseball had a
good start to their year what do you do
yeah we talked to the commissioner last
week and I said you know this this might
be your legacy we might look back 20
years from now and say you know what
commissioner Manfred did anybody
save the game is maybe a little overly
uh hyped but he modernized the game he
might be remembered for modernizing the
game 100 then and I think this is a
commissioner who needed a legacy moment
you know I mean you know Commissioners
get killed in all the sports anyway but
for whatever the reason Silber doesn't
get killed because the players love him
you know Goodell the NFL is it is in is
impregnable so he almost he kind of he
can deal with it and nobody cares about
the hockey that much so really Manford
he's he gets pounded all the time he got
pounded last year at the lockout he gets
pounded at times when you know sometimes
when he you know the piece of metal with
the World Series you know his verbiage
can get him in trouble yeah and I think
unwarranted and he's not they're not
fair about it but I think in this
situation he comes across very well and
I think this was a good deal so I think
he needs a legacy moment so good for him
if this turns out to be exactly that
he's Chris Mad Dog Russo host of Mad Dog
Unleashed on Sirius XM channel 82 host
of high heat on MLB Network Draymond
Green says oh great do you want to have
a minimum 65 games to be eligible for
postseason honors and first second third
Team all NBA you're going to have bums
who are going to make these teams
because they're going to play more than
65 games and maybe some of these Stars
won't I don't know what the solution
here is Chris but is that asking too
much to say you got to play in at least
65 games
I'm with you a thousand percent I mean
geez that for the money they charge to
go to these games games and we can't
guarantee you know for instance I had a
call a week or so ago we spent six
hundred dollars to get two tickets to
see the Philly at Denver and bead and
embiid didn't play any game now I know
he had calf soreness and he's played you
know 65 games for the year I'm with you
a thousand percent bird Jabar Wilt
Russell Jordan I mean they must be just
really you can't play 75 ball games in
an NBA season I mean to me it's a joke
and I I I you know that's 20 of the
Season you miss if you don't play 65
games to be eligible to win the MVP I
mean is that asking too much I mean you
know listen when you and I we got
contracts we're supposed to work a
certain amount of shows we're here in
the big events you and I are here in the
Masters we're here with this we're here
with that you know there's a sense of
responsibility you can't play 70 games
in an NBA regular season is the NBA
regular season that worthless that you
know it means nothing and you can get
away with playing 56
well then why are they charging me a
fortune for the tickets why are they
making a big deal about the playing
thing who gives about the who cares
about the plan it make any difference
you know don't play you know play 40
games and we separate who the good teams
are and then play months of NBA playoff
basketball they got a major problem with
it you and I are old school but if you
can't play 65 games my God that's a
disgrace if you think you should still
win an MVP and the MVP should mean
something
it should mean something the MVP award
you should want to win an MVP what the
players are telling you by moaning and
Glory about 65 games is they don't care
about the MVP that's it that's it how do
you keep the Jets Aaron Rodgers story
fresh on your show don't you don't I
haven't talked about it this week now
you and I are old school hosts and
that's why you know you know people you
know our fans like it because you and I
care about a little baseball you know we
care about Masters on opening day on a
Thursday you and I care about the NCAA
tournament you know you and I care about
just NFL football and so as a result of
that you know you did SportsCenter for
100 years you care about that stuff I've
been doing this since 89 I care about
all the sports and now today it's almost
like it's football 24 7 and when I can
get around and get away from it for a
month or two and this is the time you
can do it you know right around the
football right around the end of the
season before a week or two before the
draft I'm gonna do it so for me to sit
there and talk hour upon hour about
Lamar Jackson to sit there and break
down the Jets giving up a second or a
first round pick Rogers go not go oh
enough already I I I can't let me do
something else so I enjoy this time of
the year where I can we can break and do
a little golf we can do a little NCAA
maybe we can do a little NHL first shot
in the playoffs how good are the Bruins
you know so from that standpoint I enjoy
this period And I I'm happy I do enough
of the Jackson on the ESPN one day a
week I haven't done it at all this week
on the radio I haven't done it maybe you
have I haven't done that much no because
I can't add to it and that's why I
always say if I can and I can advance it
then I will I won't check a box and say
I've got to talk about Aaron Rodgers
every day I've got to talk about LeBron
every day I don't want our Dak Prescott
every dad I just don't want to do that I
don't that's not fair to the audience to
say hey I'm going to troll you because
these are the top stories or top people
we're supposed to talk about every day
well you and I again I don't script the
show I don't think you do either I mean
you go in there and you know you have an
idea what you want to talk about but you
go when you do your thing and you know
too many people say oh I better do
football God it's football I I better do
the draft I better do a little more I I
that's what people want to hear about I
don't look at it that way I do what
interests me and the day that it's not
interesting to the other to the people
out there is the day I'm gonna leave and
Chris we're not interested in what you
think I don't care about the sunshine
double and Memphis you know once they
tell me that I gotta leave and you're
the same way Dan you're the same way are
you all in you can talk about what you
want to talk about are you all in on
Rogers going to the gym is it the right
move okay I think that's good for the
Jets yes I am okay I think the Jets have
to do it they haven't made the playoffs
in millions of years they've won one
Super Bowl they sort of have a now team
I wouldn't give up the first round pick
there's no reason no reason to do that
Packers are dead Packers have to get rid
of them and there's nobody else yeah
Tennessee he's not going to go to
Tennessee so the Packers are really they
have nowhere to go so it's going to be a
second round pick but I am all in on the
Jets they have to bring him in here
after I think Roger says plenty left
who's closer to winning a championship
the Jets or the Knicks
the Jets
it's so hard to win there Dan you know
the Knicks have had a good year I mean
they're going to be 50 50 to beat
Cleveland
you know the best players always win do
the Knicks have the top 10 player on
their team they really don't and bead
Tatum Kawhi Curry
jokic
uh uh Anthony Davis the next on Brunson
and brunson's very good but he's not you
know I mean a is he's not Giannis and
those are the guys that end up winning
the Championships so the Knicks got the
respectability made the playoffs like
they all do in the NBA if they ever win
around against Cleveland will have a
parade in New York but the Jets with the
quarterback and the fact that uh you
know if Pete Mahomes won't be easy but I
do think the Jets are closer than the
Knicks are winning a title I'll leave
you leave you with this if I gave a New
York Sports Fan One Wish
well that's a good question
that's a very good question now I my
suggestion would be and I'm not a New
York fan
is to get a new owner for the Knicks
okay you're looking at it from a
standpoint of not playoff success it
could be anything
because I don't think you get playoff
success if you have that I think I think
you hit it I think that that's a
brilliant job
I think that I wouldn't have thought of
that that's it it's stolen now that is
tempered a little bit late lately
because the Knicks have had a good year
and they brought Brunson in and Leon
Rose is going to put a good job and they
like Thibodaux and for the most part he
stayed out of the way now he's gotten
wrapped up with this stupid you know
facial recognition
which is so petty yeah uh but I I you
know and the Rangers are good and he
owns them too so you got to look at it
from that standpoint but that's a good
one Dan but did don't ever get mad at
you
or Mike when you guys criticized and did
he hold it against you guys when you
would criticize him uh you know he was
pretty good you know he a little bit you
know but we took his side with Marv
Albert which was a big deal
you know and they had the issue with
Marv and it was about the money and they
let him go and they brought Brian in and
everything else uh yeah it's always a he
now he says you know he doesn't listen
to me necessarily on serious so I'm not
as wrapped up in it and you know what
might annoy Dolan compared to say the
old days 20 years ago when you might say
something no we were very pro-checkots
and so that bothered him because he made
the change and check its left and and
the Knicks have been terrible and uh and
we were poor Van Gundy and they had a
problem there too so there was probably
a time in the late 90s early 2000s where
he was annoyed at us uh but I think for
the most part I I haven't had a lot of
dealings with him and remember
he was very good to me and Mike with the
show that we did at times at uh Radio
City how we did that Reunion yeah yeah
he donated the building he gave us the
garden of Dreams monument and you know
we did the whole show for the MSG
charity and he was great with that so we
basically have had a good relationship
with him but I think your point is well
taken I think the average fan would say
you know what let's get a new Nick owner
I think you're right good to talk to you
man dog thanks for joining us Danny how
much I enjoy it you're the best have a
great weekend thank you bud that's uh
Christopher Mad Dog Russo